guten Abend schön dass ihr dabei seid
willkommen zu ZDF heute live auf der
Suche nach dem verschollenen Tauchboot
Titan haben sucht Teams Klopfgeräusche
wahrgenommen möglicherweise könnte das
eine Spur sein möglicherweise wissen wir
in ein paar Minuten mehr um 7 Uhr will
die US-Küstenwache eine Pressekonferenz
geben die schauen wir uns dann gleich
zusammen an hier für die fünf Menschen
an Bord wird die Zeit immer knapper
sollten Sie noch am Leben sein auch das
wissen wir nicht wird der Sauerstoff in
der Kapsel nicht mehr allzu lange
ausreichen in der Zwischenzeit kommen
auch immer mehr Zweifel an der
Sicherheit der Titan auf wurden
Warnungen ignoriert darüber sprechen wir
gleich mit dem Fregattenkapitän ARD und
Geschäftsführer des Verbands deutsche
U-Bootfahrer Jürgen Weber er war auch
bei den Dreharbeiten zur ZDF-Serie das
Boot als Berater dabei und wir reden mit
meiner Kollegin Brigitte Saar deren
Leidenschaft seit vielen Jahren die
Titanic ist sie kennt sich nicht nur
wahnsinnig gut aus sie ist auch schon
selbst zum Wrack runtergetaucht er
schickt uns gerne eure Fragen und
Kommentare in die Chats schreiben oder
eine E-Mail schicken ihr wisst wie es
geht aber jetzt gehen wir erstmal zu
meinem Kollegen Johannes Hanau nach New
York
hallo Johannes grüße dich
hallo grüß Dich also ich habe es gerade
gesagt gleich soll es in Boston eine
Pressekonferenz der Küstenwache geben
kannst du uns vorher auf den neuesten
Stand bringen was es jetzt mit den
Klopfgeräuschen auf sich hat
also heute Nacht hat die kanadische
Küstenwache über eine so nahboje die man
abgeworfen hatte diese Klopfgeräusche
wahrgenommen das Besondere daran ist
dass diese Klopfgeräusche wohl exakt
alle 30 Minuten auftreten was darauf
hindeutet dass es keine natürlichen
Geräusche sind sondern dass sie gemacht
sind also Menschen gemacht sind und dass
wiederum deutet darauf hin dass es
möglicherweise eine Chance gibt dass die
Besatzung der Titan noch am Leben ist
allerdings hat man große Schwierigkeiten
den Ort zu lokalisieren weil in der
titane gibt es viele lose Teile die da
unten hin und her schlingern gegen
stahlhauen also es gibt eine ganze Menge
Geräusche wohl so haben wir erfahren die
das sehr schwierig machen den genauen
Ort dieser Klopfgeräusche zu
lokalisieren die Kanada die haben jetzt
zwei weitere Schiffe in die Region
geschickt die auch die Möglichkeit haben
so nach schleppboden unter Wasser
entlang zu ziehen um vielleicht diesen
Ort genauer zu lokalisieren vorher diese
Klopfgeräusche kommen aber genau das
werden wir wahrscheinlich gleich erst
während der Pressekonferenz erfahren
und die Pressekonferenz soll um sieben
beginnen wir haben noch zwei drei
Minütchen Zeit Jonas Cup hat uns die
neuesten Ereignisse zusammengefasst
seltene Innenansichten der Titanen in
ihrem Werbevideo verspricht die Firma
Ocean Gate ihren Kunden das Abenteuer
ihres Lebens einmal die sagenumwobene
Titanic mit eigenen Augen sehen der
Geschäftsführer wird mit der einfachen
Bedienung des U-Boots wir steuern das
Boot mit diesem Gaming Controller wenn
man nach vorne will drückt man den Hebel
nach vorne wenn man zurück will zurück
und dasselbe für links und rechts
doch jenseits allen werbeanze gibt es
Sicherheitsbedenken und das nicht erst
seit gestern schon 2018 warnt die
renommierte Marine technologies Society
dieser Brief spiegelt unsere kollektive
Sorge wieder was die Entwicklung der
Titan und die geplante Titanic
Expedition angeht nach unserer
Auffassung könnte der experimentelle
Ansatz von Ocean Gate negative
Auswirkungen mit ernsthaften
Konsequenzen für alle in der Industrie
haben
experimentell auch deshalb weil die
Kapsel aus Carbon gefertigt ist sonst
bestehen U-Boote die in solche tiefen
hinabsteigen aus Metall
Johannes vielleicht vorab die Frage noch
an dich es gibt auch schon eine aus dem
Chat Jan schreibt auf Youtube was für
Boote U-Boote werden zur Suche verwendet
also diese Rettungsaktionen die da
gerade anläuft die hat eine gewaltige
Dimension oder
ja mittlerweile sind heute acht neue
Schiffe in die Region geschickt worden
bislang war das glaube ich nur zwei oder
drei mittlerweile sind es acht Leute
zugekommen darunter wie schon gesagt
zwei kanadische ähm wo Boote die
sonaborien ziehen schleppen können um
den Ort zu lokalisieren und dann ist ein
französischer Spezialschiff unterwegs
das war wohl im Atlantik musste jetzt
kommen wird heute Nacht erwartet dieses
Boot hat ein ein Mini-U-Boot oder ein
Roboter der in diese großen Tiefen gehen
kann der ist an einem Seil der kann
runtergehen die anderen Roboter Mini
U-Boote die man im Moment hat kommen gar
nicht so tief wohl und dieses Boot davon
verspricht man sich dann den Ort besser
lokalisieren zu können sollte man den
mit den so nahgeräten eingrenzen können
also dieses Boot wird dann suchen aber
das wird nicht für heute Nacht ankommen
und dann ist ein Schiff unterwegs das
auch in der Lage sein soll so ein U-Boot
dann zu heben das ist ja auch sehr
kompliziert das liegt 3.000
Leute Konferenz beginnt zusammen ein
alles klar der
rettungs- und Suchaktion die wir
gegenwärtig durchführen nahe am Werk der
Titanic wir haben Captain Jamie Frederic
heute hier für Sie eingeladen er gibt in
einen kurzen Abriss und wird danach für
Fragen zur Verfügung stehen und hier ist
kacken Frederic
ich bin Captain Jamie Frederic hier
heute von der Küstenwache und möchte
Ihnen ein Update geben zur such- und
Rettungsaktion neben mir sehen sich hier
einige Experten die wir heute hier auch
versammelt haben die gleichzeitig
natürlich nur für das große Team stehen
das hier um die Uhr rund um die Uhr
arbeitet wir wissen natürlich dass es
hier eine sehr sehr schwierige Situation
ist gerade für die Familien der
Vermissten und unsere Gedanken sind bei
ihnen und bei der co- unser Team
arbeitet unermüdlich daran um alle
Ressourcen und alle Köpfe so nah wie
möglich an diese Rettungsaktion zu
bringen und uns dafür einzusetzen dass
wir natürlich auch
die Familienmitglieder immer auf dem
Laufenden zu halten um diese zu
informieren wie die Rettungsaktion
verläuft darüber hinaus waren wir auch
im Kontakt mit den Briten und den
Franzosen und wir können sicherstellen
dass natürlich auch die Belange dieser
Länder hier beachtet werden wir sind
sehr dankbar für die Unterstützung die
wir erhalten haben vielen Dank auch hier
für
das Mitglied der königlichen Marine
dann haben wir natürlich auch in Saint
Johns hier
mehrere Experten versammelt die uns
unterstützen wir haben unsere
kanadischen Partner die uns sehr sehr
stark unterstützen und die natürlich
Kapazitäten zur Verfügung stellen seit
Beginn unserer Reaktion es ist eine sehr
komplexe Rettungsaktion die sowohl unter
Wasser als auch über Wasser stattfindet
wir bringen unsere Anstrengung zusammen
und das ist ganz kritisch wir sind ja
hat Meilen
hier in
Atlantik und auch außerhalb von St
Johnson und das ist natürlich sehr sehr
weit weg von Saint Jones und den anderen
Landgebieten und aus diesem Grunde ist
es natürlich extrem schwierig hier
wirklich die Ressourcen vor Ort zu
bringen und dann eben auch unter Wasser
zu sorgen wir haben fünf Ressourcen die
momentan auf der Oberfläche suchen wir
erwarten weitere in den nächsten Stunden
und wir erwarten auch weitere die bis
morgen früh ankommen werden wir haben
großartige Unterstützung erhalten gerade
aus der Luft auch hier äh von der
Küstenwache in Elisabeth City wir haben
hier natürlich auch Unterstützung der
kanadischen Armee erhalten wir haben
hier unterschiedliche Flüge organisiert
momentan läuft einer es läuft hier immer
weiter und auch natürlich weiter Flüge
die wir hier bis
in den Abend hinein durch P3 die
Kanadier haben gestern unter
Wassergeräusche wahrgenommen im
suchgebet wir haben hier jetzt versucht
den Ursprung dieser Geräusche zu
organisieren das ist bisher nicht von
Erfolg beschien gewesen wir machen
nichtsdestotrotz mit den Untersuchungen
weiter wir haben diese Informationen
natürlich geteilt mit der amerikanischen
Marine und das wird natürlich auch
berücksichtigt für weitere Pläne wir
sind jetzt hier
in einem sehr großen Bereich am Start
wir gehen auch tief in die Tiefe und wir
organisieren das momentan sehr sehr
gucken uns natürlich genau an wie das
Wetter ist wie die Strömungen sind und
wie das Meer sich verhält das ändert
sich ständig es ist unglaublich komplex
aufgrund der Tatsache dass das Gebet so
weit weg von der Küste ist und das so
viele unterschiedliche Nationen und so
viele unterschiedliche Ressourcen
eingebunden sind wir sind sehr dankbar
für die Ausrüstung für uns unterstützt
wird command wird weiter daran arbeiten
so schnell wie möglich hier die
Unterstützung zur bündeln und auch zu
implementieren und wir sind hier dabei
das umzusetzen wichtig ist dass wir die
Ausrüstung bald erhalten wir wollen hier
natürlich in den unterschiedlichen
suchgebieten suchen und weitersuchen 48
Stunden ist es her dass wir sehr viel
Expertise und Ressourcen mobilisieren
konnten wir haben über die Ressourcen
hinaus sich bereits genannt hatten haben
wir natürlich jetzt auch weitere
Ressourcen und Kapazitäten von der
amerikanischen Arena erhalten die jetzt
auch weiter unter Wasser suchen ich habe
sehr häufig gesagt dass es ganz wichtig
ist dass wir gemeinsam arbeiten und das
ist wirklich das entscheidende Element
hier in dieser sehr komplexen Missionen
unsere Gebete sind bei der großen bei
den Familienangehörigen und wir werden
alles uns Mögliche tun um weiter zu
arbeiten ich antworte gerne auf einige
Fragen aber ich würde hier gerne eine
Begrüßung der Teilnehmer noch einmal
vornehmen wollen
ich bin Direktor für die Operation bei
der Marine hier in diesem Gebiet
Karl harzfeld von Bootshaus einem
grafischen Institut
und ich bin ich hier auch dabei
von der Marine
Christin Butler und ich arbeite eng
zusammen mit Captain Jamie Vater Weg
hier bei der Koordination was können Sie
uns sagen zu den Geräuschen die sie
wahrgenommen haben
was haben sie bisher
herausstellen können
wie sie das hier aus in Bezug auf die
Geräusche die sie wahrgenommen haben
natürlich momentan in einer Suche und
Rettungsaktion immer noch Hoffnung und
deshalb machen wir ja auch weiter und
jetzt in Bezug auf die Geräusche kann
ich Ihnen nur sagen dass wir es nicht
wissen was diese Geräusche sind wir
haben Geräusche gehören das ist das was
wir wahrgenommen haben aus diesem Grunde
sind ja diese vor Ort was gut daran ist
ist dass wir in dem Gebiet suchen wo die
Geräusche entstanden sind wo wir sie
wahrgenommen haben und das machen wir
auch weiter und wir hoffen natürlich
dass wir dann auch weiter versuchen
können in diesen Bereichen wo die
Geräusche wahrgenommen werden können wo
sie vielleicht auch weiterhin
wahrgenommen werden können und dann
wissen wir vielleicht auch wo wir suchen
müssen
haben Sie denn regelmäßige Geräusche
nein ich hatte nichts gehört zu den 30
Minuten Abstand ich kann Ihnen das sagen
ich habe keine Ausbildung für
Unterwasser
Technologie diese Daten wurden
wahrgenommen diese Daten wurden der
Marine zur Verfügung gestellt gestern
Abend die werden analysiert die werden
weiter analysiert aber sie haben noch
keinen Aufschluss gegeben aber was
wichtig ist dass wir dort suchen wo die
Geräusche entstanden sind wie sieht die
Timeline aus wie sieht der Zeitplan aus
können Sie dazu etwas sagen
Zeitplan in Bezug worauf
das habe ich jetzt leider nicht hören
können dass nicht auf Mikro war wir
gucken uns einfach mal die Zahlen an es
ist ganz ganz wichtig dass wir noch
einmal auf den Sauerstoff zu sprechen
kommen es gibt sehr viel andere Daten
die wir natürlich auch im Kopf haben
müssen und wir gucken uns das an und wir
machen das auch immer wenn wir suchen
aber Sauerstoff ist nicht das einzige
wir konzentrieren uns momentan auf die
Suchaktion wir stehen in einem Dialog
und wir suchen im Moment darum geht es
gibt eine such- und Rettungsaktionen auf
alle Fälle stehen wir hier hinter dieser
Suche und Rettungsaktion und wir werden
alle Ressourcen dafür einsetzen dass wir
die Titan finden und die Crewmitglieder
auf finde ich machen
haben Sie ein Objekt wahrgenommen was
glaube ich die Frage gut dazu kann ich
Ihnen folgendes sagen
wir haben hier ganz unterschiedliche
Ressourcen und Expertisen vereinbart
welche
tiefer haben wir 4000 Meter 4000 Meter
wir haben morgen dann noch einmal andere
Ressourcen die reinkommt die noch mal
tiefer gehen können also nach einem
Objekt hatten sie gefragt gestern hatten
wir ja ein ähm
Aufklärer gehabt dann weiß man immer
dass es auf dem Meer Dinge gibt die dort
schwimmen wir haben uns das angehört wir
haben es nicht als Müll identifizieren
können wir sehen wirklich häufig in
einer aktiven Suchaktion nach solchen
Objekten und wir sehen diese wir nehmen
die wahr
die Geräusche wann haben Sie die
Geräusche zum ersten Mal wahrgenommen
wie sah es da aus haben Sie
Informationen in Bezug auf
Lebensmittel glaube ich gut ich kann
Ihnen dazu folgendes sagen dass
verschiedene Geräusche wahrgenommen
wurden und zwar gestern und wir haben
die Ressourcen darauf angesetzt wir
haben das lokalisiert und wenn es um
Lebensmittel und Wasservorräte gibt dann
gibt es wohl limitierte begrenzte Ration
es gibt wohl etliches was man an Ration
zur Verfügung hat wie viel Hoffnung gibt
es noch jetzt wo wir diese Geräusche
gehört haben ich glaube man muss ja ganz
behutsam vorgehen wir müssen immer
Hoffnung haben aber ich kann ihn
natürlich nicht sagen was diese
Geräusche sind was ich in momentan sagen
kann und das ist glaube ich ganz wichtig
ist es wir gucken was diese Geräusche
sind und das ist wichtig
wie sieht es denn jetzt aus in Bezug auf
den Status der Operation sie suchen
weiter und ja
also die P3 hat heute auch Geräusche
gehören glaube ich ich würde jetzt hier
vielleicht hier noch einmal das Wort
abgeben hier liegen ja mehr Kenntnisse
auch vor in Bezug auf unter Wasser
Akustik und vielleicht können wir hierzu
etwas hören es gibt Geräusche ja es gibt
Geräusche unter der Oberfläche des
Ozeans vielleicht kann ich hier noch mal
übergeben
der Ozean ist ja etwas sehr komplexes es
gibt menschliche Geräusche es gibt
natürliche Geräusche und es ist ganz
häufig sehr schwierig zu unterscheiden
wo die Quelle dieser Geräusche liegt es
gibt unterschiedliche Zentren die sind
in diesem Gebiet es werden Daten
zurückgeschickt wir haben wirklich die
weltbesten Daten Analysten am Start die
gucken sich diese Daten an die
analysieren diese Daten und danach
werden Entscheidungen getroffen wir sind
ja hier in beratende Funktion und unsere
Expertise zu Folge haben wir hier die
Aufgabe die Entscheidung auf Grundlage
von Daten zu treffen und wir schließen
nicht so aus
multiple Berichte zu Geräuschen und
alles wird analysiert wird nach Mustern
analysiert und berichtet wie klingt denn
so ein Geräusch
die Geräusche sind wie gesagt im Meer im
Ozean sehr komplex man muss wirklich
eine akustische Analyse durchführen man
muss auch das Ganze in einen Kontext
einordnen die Geräusche wurden
beschrieben als klopfend aber wie gesagt
man muss das ganze große sehen und man
muss dann natürlich auch
andere Geräusche eliminieren die nicht
von der Titan ausgehen
könnte es auch sein dass es ein Schiff
im Ozean gibt oder könnte es auch sein
dass Säuger vielleicht zu diesem
Geräuschen beitragen also meiner
Erfahrung nach gibt es akustische
Geräusche die vielleicht menschlich
klingen aber ich kann Ihnen versichern
dass diejenigen die dieser Aufnahmen
anhören wirklich gut ausgebildet sind es
gibt viele Schiffe und von diesen
Schiffen gehen natürlich Geräusche aus
wir müssen all das natürlich eliminieren
wir müssen das im zeitlichen Verlauf
analysieren und weder Captain Frederick
uns gesagt hat wir suchen im richtigen
Gebiet wir suchen im richtigen Gebet und
wenn wir das weiter betreiben wenn wir
weiter analysieren wenn der
unterschiedliche Muster weiter verfolgen
wenn wir im richtigen Gebiet suchen dann
tun wir das beste Möglichkeit was wir
tun können mit den bestmöglichen Leuten
die hier an diesem Fall arbeiten
wie sieht es aus in Bezug auf Ressourcen
die dort zur Verfügung stellen wie wird
es weitergehen ist die Frage welche
Systeme können Sie dazu welches System
haben sie im Kopf diese Soundsysteme im
Ozean
das ist wirklich eine Ausrüstung das ist
ein Kran es gibt unterschiedliche
Ausrüstungsgegenstände die momentan
eingeflogen werden aus den Jones was ich
vielleicht noch sagen kann was auch
wichtig ist es folgendes dass die AW
Kapazitäten die bald reinkommen das sind
wirklich wunderbare Ressourcen wir haben
die Franzosen die bald zu uns stoßen das
französische Team die uns mit unserer
mit ihrer Ausrüstung helfen mit der
französischen Ausrüstung helfen mit
einem französischen Schiff das sind
wunderbare
Anlagen und dann liegen uns mehr
Ressourcen vor und dann können wir
gucken wo der beste Ort ist zu suchen
wie viel Tage
kann sie dann noch optimistisch sein
dass sie hier etwas aufhören fragen Sie
wie viele Tage sie dem ganz noch gehen
also
wir müssen optimistisch und
hoffnungsvoll bleiben gerade wenn wir
nach such und Rettungsaktionen gucken
wir stecken mittendrin in der Suche und
Rettungsaktion ich möchte jetzt hier
nicht diskutieren wann das enden Mark
ich kann Ihnen an dieser Stelle
natürlich sagen wie dieser Prozess sein
würde
der Küstenwache hat natürlich täglich
mit such und Rettungsaktion zu tun und
manchmal finden wir nicht was wir suchen
und dann muss man wirklich ganz
sorgfältig abwägen welche Faktoren hier
vorlegen und es gibt hier sehr viele
Faktoren die man einschätzen muss und
man schätzt diese Faktoren ein und
manchmal muss man natürlich auch harte
Entscheidung treffen an diesem Punkt
sind wir noch nicht aber wenn wir weiter
suchen dann könnten wir irgendwann
vielleicht an diesem Punkt sein aber
noch einmal an diesem Punkt sind wir
nicht sind wir noch nicht und das ist
ein Punkt den wir mit den Familien
besprechen werden bevor ich es mit ihnen
dis
wie viel länger kann man denn überleben
ohne Sauerstoff ich kann hier keine
Zahlen nennen ich kann hier keine Zahlen
nennen ich habe hier keine Prozentpunkte
ich kann noch einmal sagen es ist ein
Datenpunkt den wir haben wir müssen uns
andere Punkte angucken
die Geräusche wie oft werden diese
Geräusche denn wahrgenommen können Sie
dazu noch einmal etwas sagen
wie sind die Intervalle für diese
Geräusche
gut die Geräusche wurden gehört von
einer kanadischen P3 und das war heute
morgen und auch gestern der Fall ich
weiß nicht genau ob es diese 30 Minuten
Abstande gab aber was wichtig ist ist
dass wir wirklich dort suchen wir sind
dort mit den Kapazitäten am Stand Start
und arbeiten dort weiter mit unserer
Suche
wie hoch ist denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass das Schiff noch steuerbar ist noch
operativ ist also ob das noch steuerbar
ist oder ob das auf dem Meeresboden
liegt das ist alles spekulativ das ist
alles spekulativ und wir sind hier keine
Spekulanten wir suchen wir suchen und
retten und wir tun das bestmögliche was
wir tun können eine Frage noch
wie sieht es aus in Bezug auf die
Unterstützung die sie erhalten von der
Royal Lady und den anderen Ressourcen
wir hatten ja nach zusätzlichen
unter Wasser unterstützungskapazitäten
gefragt wir haben das erhalten hier von
Seiten der Royal Lady hier ist ja einer
von vielen der uns hier unterstützen und
wir sind sehr dankbar gegenüber der
britischen Regierung für diese
Unterstützung ich glaube der Plan ist
wahrscheinlich
einfach weitermachen ich möchte hier gar
nicht mehr einsteigen in diese
Diskussion wenn es Entwicklung gibt
werden wir Ihnen das Metall vielen Dank
vielen Dank meine Damen und Herren
vielen Dank dass ihr heute hier bei der
Pressekonferenz dabei waren das ist das
Ende danke schön
ja das war die Pressekonferenz der
US-Küstenwache zur Suche nach dem
verschollenen Tauchboot Titan ich fass
mal kurz das allerwichtigste zusammen
also Captain Frederick hat bestätigt
Klopfgeräusche wurden gehört eine
kanadische P3 hat heute morgen und
gestern diese Klopfgeräusche
wahrgenommen es ist aber bisher nicht
gelungen diese Geräusche eben zu
lokalisieren und dieses Tauchboot zu
finden er hat auch nicht bestätigt wie
es heute hieß dass diese Klopfgeräusche
alle 30 Minuten wahrgenommen werden
konnten das hat er bislang nicht
bestätigt aber es gibt sie darüber würde
ich jetzt gerne sprechen mit meiner
Kollegin Brigitte Saar ich habe es
vorhin schon gesagt sie ist nicht nur
Journalistin bei uns im ZDF sondern sie
ist auch Titanic Expertin und eben schon
zum Wrack selbst runtergetaucht vor
einigen Jahren und ich begrüße den
Fregattenkapitän ad und Geschäftsführer
des Verband deutsch-fahrer Jürgen Weber
der eben auch die Dreharbeiten zur
ZDF-Serie das Boot beraten hat guten
Abend
schönen guten Abend genau das muss man
auch dazu sagen sie kennen sich durch
ihre gemeinsame Leidenschaft und ich
würde gerne bei dir
beginnen Brigitte du bist Journalistin
wenn hast die Pressekonferenz auch
gesehen das war jetzt eigentlich mehr so
ein Update wirklich was neues gibt es
eigentlich nicht
ja man muss da glaube ich ein bisschen
zwischen den Zeilen lesen also es gab zu
diesem Klopfgeräuschen nicht viel Neues
ähm es hat sich leider nicht
bewahrheitet dass die ihn wirklich einer
solchen Regelmäßigkeit kommen dass man
direkt drauf schließen kann dass die
menschlichen Ursprung sein müssen aber
es wurde zumindest bestätigt dass sie
mehrfach gekommen sind und das was ganz
spannend ist was man an der PK auch
sehen kann ist einfach mit wie viel
Material jetzt alle die irgendwas
anbieten können ausrücken sofort unter
welchen Zeitdruck und das macht ja nicht
leichter auch wenn man natürlich sehr
dankbar ist dass diese zusätzlichen
Tauchroboter so nah Anlagen und so dass
sie alle vor Ort sind das bedeutet aber
auch dass jetzt ganz viele zusätzliche
Schiffe da vor Ort sind und die müssen
ja auch koordiniert werden dass man sich
da sozusagen nicht gegenseitig über die
Füße fährt und das z.B die
Schiffsschrauben von all diesen Schiffen
der da jetzt unterwegs sind nicht am
Ende sozusagen das Signal unhörbar
machen nachdem man eigentlich sucht also
deswegen ich glaube was man herauslesen
kann ist dass die wirklich Vollgas geben
dass die alles Material was sie haben
jede Chance da irgendwie Erkenntnisse
rauszuziehen jetzt einsetzen dass es da
auch ganz kurze Dienstwege gibt und dann
muss man einfach mal schauen ob sie es
wirklich schaffen diese Quelle dieses
tongeräusches weiter einzugrenzen weil
man darf ja auch nicht vergessen das ist
ja keine flache Karte 2D auf der ich
einfach sozusagen mit dem Zirkel zwei
Richtungen von zwei soundbojen
übereinander lege und wo dann der
Kreuzungspunkt ist da ist da auch die
Karte die die Kapsel oder was auch immer
diese Geräusche von sich gibt sondern da
ist ja noch 4000 m Wassersäule drunter
und dann dort in dieser Wassersäule
dieses kleine Boot zu finden teilweise
auch mit Robotern die hauptsächlich nur
mit Kameras arbeiten das ist wirklich
eine riesen Herausforderung da würde ich
gerne einhaken Ulrich Beckmann hat
nämlich eine Frage auf Youtube er fragt
wird die Größe des Suchgebietes nicht
maßlos überschätzt das Wetter von
tausenden Quadratkilometern gesprochen
selbst wenn eine Meeresströmung das Boot
erfasst haben sollte dann fünf
Stundenkilometer vom tauchort
ja gut das der Kreis in dem man suchen
muss der wird im Prinzip mit jeder
Stunde und mit jedem Tag größer am
Sonntag wo man also den Kontakt zum
U-Boot verloren hat war es tatsächlich
so dass man sagt wenn die jetzt
versuchen aufzutauchen dann kann man
ungefähr sagen wie die Strömung da unten
im Mittel sind es gibt stärkeres gibt
schwächere dann könnten die beim Weg
nach oben so und so viel abgetrieben
sein jetzt wenn sie aber in dieser Säule
ja schon seit Sonntag sind werden sie ja
immer weiter vom Wasser mitgenommen das
heißt am Montag könnten sie schon weiter
in eine Richtung kommen am Dienstag noch
weiter und diese Strömungen sind nicht
zwingend identisch mit den Strömungen an
der Wasseroberfläche also man kann jetzt
nicht einfach sagen hier oben wenn man
im Wasser ist treibt man nach Südosten
jetzt müsste dann eine Tauchkapsel egal
wo in dieser Wassersäule auch in die
Richtung getrieben sein deswegen ja die
machen ein sehr großes Suchgebiet man
muss aber auch sagen diese Flugzeuge die
sind ja so oder so in der Luft ja also
deswegen ähm ob da macht man natürlich
jetzt auch nicht den Fehler und schaltet
die Sensoren die man gleich einschalten
müsste um im Kern Zielgebiet zu sein
erst zu spät ein deswegen der Einwurf
stimmt das es gibt ein Kerngebiet in der
Mitte das ist wahrscheinlicher und das
hat man gehe ich mal davon aus auch als
erstes intensiv angeschaut und jetzt
zusätzlich erweitert man natürlich
einfach weil man möchte es nicht
ausschließen
okay haben Herr Weber ich habe ganz
viele Fragen hier aber ich habe auch
ganz viele Fragen im Chat und den würde
ich jetzt mal den Vorrang geben Sophia
fragt wie lange würde es denn dauern bis
Hilfe kommt sobald man die Titan
lokalisiert hat
es ist eigentlich ein System unterwegs
das nennt sich faders und soweit ich
orientiert bin kann das nicht nur mit
der Schiff sondern auch der
Luftfahrzeug verbracht werden
das wäre dann relativ schnell vor Ort
könnte muss mal kurz nachrechnen
gegen 20 Uhr heute im Zielgebiet sein
ich habe ein bisschen zur Seite weil ich
mein speziell gehabt würde gegen 20 Uhr
am Zielgebiet sein und dieses
bergungssystem von den Amerikanern ist
aber nicht alles denn das kann nur ein
Teil nach oben gießen wir bräuchten
zusätzlich mit Sicherheit so eine Art
Roboter von mir ja schon gesprochen
haben der auf dem französischen Fest der
dann beispielsweise zu dem hoffentlich
gefunden
sich hin bewegt dort eine Stadt was sie
irgendwie anbringt und den Rest der Teil
was das andere Ufer das andere das
andere Ende anbringt an dem an diesem
System und dann könnte eine Werbung
vonstatten gehen aber keine Bergung ohne
ja sie haben gerade die Pressekonferenz
auch gesehen und da hat Captain
Frederick gesagt wir bleiben
optimistisch wir bleiben hoffnungsvoll
das müssen wir auch weil wir eben in so
einer Rettungsmission unterwegs sind
welche Chancen sehen Sie die vermissten
noch Leben zu finden
ich glaube können hart viel der uns
Kraft der Kanal ja hat mich wieder zu
meinem natürlichen Pessimismus geführt
indem er ganz Glück und klar seine
sozialographische Kenntnisse über
Geräusche
den Zuschauer den Zuhörern nahe gebracht
hat und fakt ist wir haben weder den
Rhythmus von den 33 Minuten der mal
irgendwo aufgetaucht ist noch können wir
direkt was dazu sagen was das für ein
Geräusch ist das einzige muss ich sagen
wo ich sehr viel Hoffnung
ist der Einsatz der Kanadier mit der
Petri Ryan das ist ein Jagdflugzeug die
Leute sind darin geschult U-Boote zu
suchen und die haben ja eben auch diese
diese solo Bojen wenn die jetzt unten
auf dem Meer liegen oder wie weit sie
immer unterlassen dann sind eben schon
sagte Kreuzbein und durchaus denkbar
wenn ich so ein ganzes pattern von zehn
bojenigen der Hund liegen lege um dieses
um diese Position
dann kann ich vielleicht Glück haben und
drei vier haben
Erfassung passiv dieses Geräusch und
dann kann ich im Flugzeug oben diese
Position festlegen die anderen beiden
Sachen die genannt worden sind sind die
Fregatten oder Corvetten was immer von
den Kanarien die so wie es der Fachmann
ausdrücken würde mit einem barrier
bedeckt so eine ausgestattet sind also
entschlossen oder was sie hinterher
ziehen und auf verschiedene Tiefen
einsetzen können dieses kann sowohl
passiv als auch aktiv genutzt werden
vielleicht noch meine Frage an dich
Brigitte Entschuldigung du warst ja wie
gesagt schon mal in so einem Tauchboot
es gibt eine Frage von Nina auf Youtube
mit welchen Gegenständen in dem U-Boot
ist es denn überhaupt möglich diese
Klopfgeräusche zu erzeugen
diese Klopfgeräusche kann man
tatsächlich ohne Gegenstände erzeugen du
musst ja letztendlich nur mit Händen und
Füßen gegen die Hülle schlagen also die
haben ja an Bord ein Titanic Experten
der gleichzeitig früher für die
französische Marine gearbeitet hat dort
auch in führender Position der
vermutlich aus der Zeit auch
irgendwelche Abläufe und Szenarien im
Kopf hat was möglich ist dass Sie
gefunden werden und was sie machen
können dass sie auch die entsprechenden
Geräusche abgeben also das alles jetzt
hoch spekulativ dass die Kapsel noch
intakt ist dass die die Mannschaft an
Bord sich so einen Plan zurechtgelegt
hat und dass sie dann einfach sagen eben
sowas wie wir versuchen das regelmäßig
zu machen damit die eine bessere Chance
haben uns von Störgeräuschen von
zufälligen Geräuschen zu unterscheiden
und dann kann man da mit
der Hand mit Gegenständen die sie zur
Verfügung haben mit dem iPhone dass man
mitgebracht hat mit der Kamera oder
irgend sonst was kann man da einfach
Radau machen das reicht im Prinzip schon
das macht kaum einen Unterschied
ob man da jetzt ein harten langen
Gegenstand in eine Latte gegen die Wand
knallen will die man nicht hätte oder ob
man halt einfach ja hämmert
wir hatten kurz vor der Sendung die
Gelegenheit mit Alexander Waibel zu
sprechen er ist 2021 mit der Titan zum
fragt der Titanic getaucht mit dem
Tauchboot was eben jetzt vermisst wird
lass uns das kurz zusammen anschauen ich
hatte ihnen eingangs gefragt wie lange
er damals gebraucht hat um eben runter
zum Wrack zu kommen denn es heißt ja der
der Kontakt nach etwa einer Stunde 45
jetzt abgerissen war
es heißt der Kontakt zur Titanen sei
nach etwa einer Stunde 45 abgebrochen
damit man eine Vorstellung bekommt wie
lange haben Sie damals gebraucht bis sie
zum Frack der Titanic runter kamen es
geht im Wesentlich zwei Stunden nach
unten und zwei Stunden nach oben und man
hat dann zweieinhalb Stunden
Meeresgrund es ist ja eine enorme Tiefe
4000 m und der Druck ist
unglaublich hoch sind 400 Mal die
atmosphärische der Druck an der
Oberfläche und diese Aussage eine Stunde
75 Minuten macht mich natürlich stutzig
denn es sieht dann eher so aus und auch
die Kommentare dass
das keine das waren ja auch er wird
nicht berichtet von irgendwelchen
messages die geschickt und während dass
man den Boden erreicht hat also es kann
durchaus sein dass da irgendwie schon
was passiert war auf dem Weg nach unten
wäre jetzt mal meine Spekulation aber
ich weiß es natürlich auch nicht ich
lese auch dieselben Berichte die Sie
lesen ist nur so aus der Erfahrung zwei
Stunden ist oder was man braucht
wir haben viele Schilderungen viele
Mutmaßungen gehört wie es in so einer
Kapsel sein muss sie haben das einmal
eigene Leib erlebt beschreiben Sie uns
die Situation wie ist so eine Expedition
eigentlich
prima sich wir haben Aufnahmen es geht
eigentlich sehr freundlich zu und die
Teilnehmer sind ja haben entweder eine
wissenschaftliche Mission oder sind
Teilnehmer die
[Musik]
dabei Teil als als Passagiere oder als
Mission specialist dabei sind sie lernen
sich vorher schon kennen man guckt auch
dass sie sage ich mal emotional stabil
sind so dass man wenn man dann erstmal
die Entscheidung getroffen hat und sich
versichert hat dass es sicher genug ist
dann hat man eigentlich ein Team das
dann einfach das ausführt also ich hatte
während der Fahrt dann keine Angst oder
keine Zeit über irgendwelche Sachen
nachzudenken dieser Art man hört dann
auch auf dem Weg nach unten Musik weil
nicht viel passiert das ist ja
stockdunkel draußen man ist ein Sandwich
man redet über alles Mögliche und hört
etwas Musik und jetzt eigentlich guter
Dinge freut sich auf das was man dazu
erleben wird und auch sehen wird oder
untersuchen wird und führt dann im
Wesentlichen dass das aus was man
geplant hat also ich denke nicht der
gehört dass da irgendwie jetzt große
emotionale
Ängste oder Gefühle an der Stelle das
ist mir dann schon reichlich spät
ja aber sie beschreiben das jetzt so wie
so ein Bootsausflug sie hatten ist das
nicht mulmiges Gefühl wenn man in so
eine Kapsel steigt man weiß man steigt
jetzt in solche Tiefen hinab zur
sagenumwobenen legendären Titanic also
haben sie sich zu jedem Zeitpunkt sicher
gefühlt
eigentlich ja ich muss sagen die
Aussagen die man so jetzt in der Presse
hört von wegen dass da so ein
Himmelfahrtskommando für Reiche die sie
jetzt mal schnell irgendwie sich das
reinziehen wollten das kann ich so nicht
unterstützen es wurde meiner Ansicht
nach sehr viel getan um das so sicher
wie möglich zu machen man ist ja 9 Tage
auf dem Schiff man fährt dorthin man hat
Vorträge und Diskussion mit anderen
Wissenschaftlern die über über so wohl
wissenschaftliche Experimente als auch
über die Geschichte der Titanic
berichten man setzt sich mit der ganzen
Lage auseinander mit dem Wrack selber
man setzt sich mit den
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen es wird z.B auf
dem Schiff eine eine
sicherheits-training durchgeführt auf
dem in der in dem Boot selber in dem
Schiff selber wird das Brot ja erst Ende
auf einer Plattform ins Wasser gelassen
dann bevor irgendwas passiert wird das
diese Plattform gesenkt das U-Boot
schwimmt dann an der Oberfläche dann
werden noch mal alle Systeme
durchgecheckt über Funk das ist so wie
dann in den Weltraumflügen wie man das
in den Filmen kennt dass man dann sagt
wird alles gestoppt und man sagt dann
dieses System ist go dieses System ist
go und so weiter und erst am Ende wenn
alles wirklich perfekt ist dann wird
abgetaucht und ich hatte während unserer
Fahrt zum Beispiel das auch erlebt dass
in einem der Tauchgänge wo ein
Journalist dabei war irgendwas nicht
perfekt war und dann wurde der Tauchgang
komplett abgeblasen und man hat das Boot
wieder reingezogen das heißt da sind
schon diese Vorkehrungen dass man das
jetzt nicht einfach willkürlich tut
sondern dass man sich Zeit nimmt um das
auch sicher zu gestalten ich da denke
daher auch eher dass irgendwie etwas
katastrophales passiert sein muss wie
möglicherweise ein kompletter Ausfall
der Elektrizität oder ein Feuer oder
das Schlimmste wäre das tatsächlich das
U-Boot versagt haben könnte wegen dem
riesigen Druck aber das sind jetzt alles
Spekulationen wir wissen das ja nicht
auch muss ich dazu sagen dass die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen fürs auftauchen
man macht sich ja darüber Gedanken auch
vorher was ist denn wenn irgendwie ein
System
ausfällt komme ich dann wieder nach oben
das U-Boot hatte drei unterschiedliche
aufstiegsmethoden entweder durch die
trusters oder dass dadurch dass man Luft
in bestimmte Behälter bläst oder dadurch
dass man Gewichte abwirft und teilweise
kann das sozusagen Effekte ausgelöst
werden in dem alle im Boot sich auf die
eine Seite lehnen und ein Gewicht das
draußen hängt abfällt und es gibt eine
Reihe von solchen
Vorsichtsmaßnahmen die schon getroffen
wurden sind damit man für solche Fälle
Alternativen hatte
was also genau passiert ist
wir können eigentlich nur spekulieren
das vielleicht drei Situationen entweder
gab es ein katastrophales Versagen des
uber der U-Bootes selbst oder man ist
tatsächlich nach unten gekommen und
hat sich verirrt oder ist festgehakt das
heißt man kann sich ja auch in diesen
Metallteilen das Wracks möglicherweise
festhaken aber das würde zum Beispiel
widersprechen mit dem mit dem Ausfall
der Kommunikation oder das Boot ist
tatsächlich aufgestiegen und es ist
jetzt an der Oberfläche und man findet
es nicht denn angeblich ist da gerade
Nebel und das Boot ist auch nicht so
leicht sichtbar weil es ja leicht unter
der Wasseroberfläche liegt also viele
Möglichkeiten was hier passiert sein
könnte und alle natürlich sehr
beängstigend weil wie gesagt auch wenn
es an der Oberfläche ist kommt man nicht
ohne weiteres raus oder ein Team das die
Bergung dann durchführt und auf der
Tiefe ein zweites U-Boot runter schicken
das ein dann wieder rauszieht geht ja
auch nicht weil es gibt so viele Boote
ja gar nicht die so tief kommen also die
Situation sieht meiner Ansicht nach
schon recht ernst aus
ich danke Ihnen sehr für ihre
Schilderung
ja wie gesagt das war das Gespräch mit
Alexander Waibel dass ich eben vor der
Sendung kurz vorher aufgezeichnet habe
Herr Weber sie haben es eben auch gehört
und gesehen
Herr Weibel sagt er hat sich sicher
gefühlt er hat sich gut gefühlt es ist
wirklich sehr beängstigend dieser
Gedanke dass genau in diesem gleichen
Tauchboot gerade fünf Menschen sitzen
die möglicherweise um ihr Leben kämpfen
und es gab ja auch schon vor Jahren
Sicherheitsbedenken wo sehen Sie die
Sicherheitsbedenken der Zeiten
wie sehe ich da drin dass dieses Buch
nicht zertifiziert ist darf ich mal
einfach sagen es hat keinen TÜV kann TÜV
und ich würde nie in eine solche
stahldose oder Carbon Dose steigen wo
ich von innen nicht das tun muss öffnen
kann ja wenn diese wenn ich jetzt eine
Oberfläche sind haben nur noch wenig
sauer wir sind nicht in der Lage das tun
uns zu öffnen und Luft nachzuführen da
muss ein Team von außen kommen was das
tun möchte
das ist für mich ein tauchender Tag dazu
muss man sagen damit meinen sie eben das
zuerst eben die Passagiere einsteigen
und dann diese Kapsel von außen noch mal
verschlossen wird das heißt es nicht an
der Stelle kurz beschreiben wie das
funktioniert denn der Einstieg ist
anders als bei einem militärischen
U-Boot jetzt nicht irgendwie nach oben
sondern man sieht ja von vorne diese
Halbschale mit diesem mit diesem Fenster
drin und dieses Ding muss im Prinzip
komplett abgeschraubt werden dann ist
das also wie so eine offene Cola Dose
dann gehen die Taucher hinein dann wird
diese dieser Halbkugel vorne wieder
aufgesetzt und wird dann an 16 Stellen
mit dem Rahmen wieder soweit verschraubt
hier gibt es ganz viele Fragen im Chat
bezüglich einer Leine also Jürgen fragt
warum hat man das U-Boot nicht per Leine
abgelassen Design Dennis
warum gibt es keine weiteren
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen beispielsweise
eine Verbindung zu Mutterschiff durch
einen Seil
Naomi schreibt auf Youtube ich verstehe
nicht warum diese Boote nicht an einer
Leine zum Mutterschiff hängen
Brigitte warum ist das so
also das muss man natürlich auch sagen
dass andere Tauchboote die für die
Titanic tiefen zertifiziert sind das
auch nicht haben das ist eine ziemlich
lange Leine wir reden ja dann über mehr
als 4 Kilometer die man in petto haben
muss und die behindert einen auch ein
Stück weit denn ähm da ist Wellengang
dazwischen das heißt diese Leine ist
nicht immer straff damit äh das
funktioniert und die nicht irgendwann
mal einfach reißt muss man die ein
bisschen lockerer lassen und dann ist
man da unten an einem Wrack an einem
Gegenstand der auch Zacken hat und wo
Sachen rausragen und dann dann ja dann
dann knebelt man sich im schlimmsten
Fall mit diesen Kabel und unten
irgendwie selber es gab einmal eine
Expedition da hat man ähm Kameras für
ein Livebild mit einem
Glasfaserkabel mit der Oberfläche
verbunden das war extrem aufwendig und
dann hat man in sehr limitierten Radius
aber eben im Vergleich also der
Vergleich mit der Sicherheit wird ja
jetzt geführt mit anderen Systemen die
man kennt mit
die zum Beispiel von woodsoul sind da
war ja auch ein Experte jetzt gerade bei
der Pressekonferenz und die sind alle
unabhängig vom Mutterschiff also diese
Verbindung zum Mutterschiff ist ein
Handicap und damit wäre es Fluch und
Segen zugleich und würde vielleicht ein
Problem lösen und ein anderes damit aber
erst initiieren es gibt noch eine
weitere Frage an dich war schon jemand
am Grund und hat in der Nähe der Titanic
gesucht also viele Userinnen und User
Fragen ja warum geht denn keiner runter
und schaut da mal nach also ich gebe es
gibt im Moment einfach kein weiteres
U-Boot in der Nähe dass man bemannt in
so eine tiefe schicken könnte es gibt
weltweit ganz wenige und die müssen in
der Regel mit ihrem Mutterschiff
anreisen was man versucht ist ja jetzt
unter anderem mit diesen Tauchroboter
den auch die Franzosen heute noch an die
wrackstelle schicken wollen dass man
unbemannt dort unten nach dem Rechten
schauen kann die Amerikaner nennen das
immer oh wie remote operated was halt im
Prinzip ferngesteuer Tauchroboter sind
da hat man jetzt aus Kanada auch schon
einen vor Ort der ist aber nur auch bis
in gewisse tiefen zugelassen und nutzbar
und mit diesem französischen
Tauchroboter unbemannt ferngesteuert von
oben dann auch wahrscheinlich mit einer
Kabelverbindung versucht man dann schon
in die Tiefe vorzudringen und dann muss
man aber natürlich auch sagen an der
Titanic ist das ist die Orientierung
auch nicht leicht es gibt dort kein
Licht man muss alles ausleuchten also
das ist jetzt auch nicht so dass man
dorthin geht und sich innerhalb von 10
Minuten einen Überblick verschaffen kann
dass da nichts ist sondern auch das wäre
ein Vorgang mit mehreren Stunden und
vermutlich auch unvollständig aber
nichtsdestotrotz es sieht so aus als
würde man das mit diesem französischen
Equipment dann auch versuchen
wir haben hier so viele Fragen im Chat
ich versuche mal das ein bisschen zu
bündeln damit wir möglichst viele
beantworten können herr Weber K 26 sagt
Captain Frederic hätte gesagt dass der
Sauerstoff nur einer der Faktoren sei er
fragt welche gibt es denn noch also ohne
Sauerstoff wäre doch gar keinen
überleben mehr möglich also unsere
Userinnen und User machen sich
unheimlich viele Gedanken über dieses
Thema Sauerstoff ist genau eine zweite
Frage ob es denn überhaupt möglich wäre
das U-Boot von außen mit Sauerstoff zu
versorgen über einen Anschluss sollte
man es denn gefunden haben denn die
Bergung würde ja dann noch eine ganze
Weile möglicherweise dauern
zusätzlich zum Sauerstoff haben wir das
Problem das Getränke an Bord sein müssen
Wasser am Bord sein müssen oder sollte
auch ein bisschen was zu essen da sein
wobei das Wasser Angehörige Stellenwert
hat als das Essen und die Frage
Sauerstoff von außen kann ich ganz klar
von einem das kann ich in 4000 Meter bei
diesem Equipment gar nicht durchführen
eine weitere Frage
ist es denn möglich für die Crew unter
den gegebenen Umständen Sauerstoff
einzusparen um eben die Überlebenszeit
zu verlängern
der Erfahrung immer wenn wir in
Notsituationen sind
sollen wir vor und schicken diejenigen
die wachfrei haben die eine Lösung des
Problems nicht beteiligt sind auf die
Folien damit Sie nach Möglichkeit
schlafen und schlafende Personen
verbrauchen weniger Sauerstoff
als Leute die körperliche Arbeiten
aber ist das denn das natürlich
ausgebildete Profis die für solche
Notfälle natürlich auch trainiert sind
hier sind jetzt ja auch ähm zum Teil
leihen in dieser Kapsel drin kann man in
solchen Notfällen dann überhaupt das in
die Tat umsetzen was man vorher
vielleicht in einem kurzen
Sicherheitsbriefing mal gesagt bekommen
hat
genügend Disziplin dort ist und das
Schiffsführer sich durchsetzt wird sich
das machen lassen aber das ist natürlich
Spekulation bei dieser Gruppe mit drei
schwerreichen Menschen
Brigitte es gibt noch eine Frage von
Equinox welcher Druck herrscht
eigentlich in diesem Tauchboot könnte
man es schnell nach oben ziehen oder
müsste das wegen des Druckausgleichs
langsam passieren also das ist
tatsächlich kein Problem denn in der
Kapsel herrscht durchgehend im Prinzip
der selbe Druck wie an der
Wasseroberfläche genau dafür ist der
Druckkörper ja da das ist eben keinen
Wasserdruck an die Insassen weitergibt
also du brauchst keine Dekompression das
ist nicht wie beim Tauchen wo der
Taucher wirklich physisch im Wasser ist
es gibt manchmal ein ganz leichte
Druckerhöhung einfach dadurch dass durch
den Außendruck sozusagen die die der
Deckel auf diese Kapsel noch ein
bisschen fester drauf gedrückt wird also
bei mir war es so beim wieder aussteigen
wenn man die die Kapsel dann öffnet das
ist wie so ein bisschen das Geräusch wie
wenn man eine Cola Dose öffnet und dann
hat man Druck auf den Ohren als würde
man auf dem Fernsehturm gefahren sein
aber für den Körper ist es überhaupt
kein Problem das ist tatsächlich eine
Sorge die Licht hat und Christian
schreibt auf Youtube Brigitte finde es
erstaunlich dass es für so einen Fall
keine Vorkehrungen gibt also diese
Sicherheitsbedenken und Mängel die jetzt
nach und nach irgendwie genannt werden
wer das für dich ein Grund gewesen eben
auf diese Mission auf diese Expedition
zu verzichten
also klar wenn das jetzt eine eine
derart verunfallte Kapsel ist und man
mich heute noch mal fragen würde ob ich
noch mal tauchen will würde ich die das
Risiko vielleicht anders einschätzen
aber man muss da sehr vorsichtig sein
mit diesen Kritikpunkten da wird
teilweise Kritik geübt von Leuten die
das zwar korrekt formulieren dass dann
aber leicht missverständlich ist ein
Beispiel diese Kapsel wird im Inneren
gesteuert mit einem Games Controller
haben wir ja gesehen ne das sieht aus
als würde ich eine Game Konsole steuern
das ist aber letztendlich ja nur eine
Eingabehilfe wie eine Tastatur auch sagt
kann nichts aus z.B über die Software
die dann im Hintergrund läuft und wie
professionell das ist
es gab die den Vorwurf das zum Beispiel
als Gewichte an diesen Tauchboot das
konventionelle Rohre verwendet wurden
die aus dem
Straßenbau und Hausbau gekauft wurden
und das sei doch sehr improvisiert auch
da muss man sagen ja kann man so sehen
ob das jetzt ein Sicherheitsrisiko
darstellt weiß ich nicht weil Ballast
ist Ballast ein Gewicht ist ein Gewicht
und das ist nicht besser oder schlechter
funktional wenn es als Unikat
angefertigt ist im Vergleich zu etwas
was ich frei kaufen kann also bei dieser
Analyse ob es Sicherheitsmängel gegeben
hat muss man sehr vorsichtig sein auch
diese Zertifizierung die der Jürgen
vorhin angesprochen hat ist so dass man
damals als man dieses Ding gebaut hat
man auf dem Markt wohl keine Firma
gefunden hat die diese neue Art des
Druckkörpers diese gewickelte Carbon
Röhre überhaupt ausreichend testen kann
und dann hat man sich entschieden ob das
jetzt ein Fehler war oder nicht wird
sich rausstellen dass man dann nicht
noch Jahre warte um überhaupt diesen
Test einzuleiten also die Vorwürfe sind
komplex manche können Stimmen manche
Kritik stimmt vielleicht auch nicht oder
ist ja missverständlich und bevor wir
nicht wissen was denn jetzt da unten
eigentlich das Problem war es ist
natürlich auch schwierig auf
anderen Komponenten die dann in der
Situation einwandfrei funktioniert haben
und nicht zu dieser Ausnahmesituation
geführt haben jetzt sozusagen schon
einzuprügeln also man muss da einfach
abwarten was dabei rauskommt ich glaube
auch dass die wahrscheinlichste Variante
eine ist in der irgendwann mal es keinen
Strom mehr gab und es gibt ja
Notfallszenarien auch das haben wir ja
gerade gehört es gibt mehrere
Möglichkeiten Ballast abzuwerfen auch
ohne Strom und das ist eigentlich die
Hauptkomponente die man hat als
Sicherheit wenn man im Prinzip keine
Kontrolle mehr hat dass man dann einen
Notfall auftaucht Manöver startet und
dann vielleicht nicht in zwei Stunden
wieder oben ist sondern in vier oder
fünf oder sechs Stunden und dann wäre
das schon die hauptsicherheitsmaßnahme
aber Jan Bremer fragt warum hat man den
denn nur Sauerstoffe 96 Stunden
mitgegeben er sagt das ist doch klar
dass sowas im Worst Case dann auch
passieren kann
das ist eine Frage die kann ich so nicht
beantworten aber 96 Stunden ist ja jetzt
erstmal auch nicht wenig wenn man sich
überlegt dass die von einer
Missionsdauer von acht vielleicht mal
zehn Stunden
ausgehen und es gibt einen Punkt da bin
ich mir auch immer noch nicht sicher ob
diese 26 und 90 Stunden wirklich final
sind denn zu der Zeit als dieses Schiff
gebaut wurde gab es mal die Aussage dass
man die 96 Stunden zusätzlich zu dem
Sauerstoff oder zu den Systemen an Bord
hat die für den eigentlichen Einsatz
gedacht sind so dass man zu jedem Zeit
einer Mission noch 96 Stunden hätte ich
kann nicht ganz ähm einschätzen ob das
tatsächlich auch so umgesetzt wurde oder
vielleicht auch noch mal geändert wurde
und dann ist natürlich die Frage wie
viel Sauerstoff ist genug 96 Stunden
braucht man 200 Stunden irgendwann wäre
dann die Grenze erreicht wo man im
Prinzip nur noch mit einem
Sauerstofftank fährt oder ja unterwegs
ist der dann wieder andere Probleme mit
sich bringt also die 96 Stunden dann
müsste man zunächst klären wie viel das
richtige die richtige Zeit wäre die man
überbrücken können muss
Herr Weber ich hätte noch eine Frage an
Sie von Kenneth gibt es eine Blackbox
also ähnlich wie bei Flugzeugen
davon ist mir nichts bekannt
und ich bin selbst auch einmal mit einem
tauchgut Gefahren auf 870 Meter runter
dann hatten wir sowas zu mir wenn es
nicht an Bord
und dann würde ich dich gerne noch
Fragen Brigitte eine Frage von Uli wie
oft wird im Jahr dieses Titanic frag
eigentlich durch Wissenschaftler
Touristen besucht also wie muss man sich
das vorstellen
also es gab jetzt auch lange Zeit Jahre
wo überhaupt niemand unten am Park war
dieses Tauchboot ist fertig und was das
erste Mal im Einsatz vor drei Jahren hat
im ersten Jahr eine etwas kürzere
Expedition gemacht mit so mehreren Teil
Expeditionen wir haben ja auch schon
gehört dass da die Passagiere einer
Tauchsaison nicht alle von Anfang bis
Ende an Bord sind sondern dass man immer
wieder mit dem Land hin und her pendelt
um die bereits getauchten abzugeben und
neue zu holen letztes Jahr war so eine
Expedition dieses Jahr waren auch schon
mehrere Teil Expeditionen das heißt die
erste hat in der zweiten Maiwoche
angefangen und die aktuelle wäre jetzt
der fünfte Teil Abschnitt und natürlich
war geplant wenn es genügend
zahlungskräftigte interessierte
Sponsoren gibt oder Passagiere gibt dass
die nächsten Jahre vorzusetzen das war
bisher ja auch ein vielversprechendes
Geschäftsmodell wo also sozusagen reiche
dafür zahlen und dann gleichzeitig
wissen Wissenschaftler eingeladen werden
kostenlos im Rahmen dieser Expeditionen
ihre Wissenschaft zu betreiben dass man
so eine eine Partnerschaft hat aus
Geldgebern die auch was lernen und auch
was sehen können und Wissenschaft die
über diese Geldgeber überhaupt erst die
Forschung bezahlt bekommen liebe
Brigitte lieber Herr Weber ich möchte
ganz herzlich dafür danken dass Sie uns
diese diese Welt diese Unterwasserwelt
näher gebracht haben uns irgendwie
anschaulich erklärt haben und uns eben
auch erklärt haben was da eben gerade
vor sich geht und welche Bedenken und
Sicherheitsmängel ist da gegeben haben
könnte vielen lieben Dank einen schönen
Abend noch tschüss
ja und ich möchte mich auch bei Euch
ganz herzlich bedanken für die vielen
vielen Fragen und ich hoffe dass wir
ganz ganz viele davon stellen konnten
ich wünsche euch noch einen guten Abend
und wir halten euch natürlich weiter auf
dem laufenden seit der Erfolg live
macht's gut tschüss